[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend die
olympischen winterspiele in peking sind
vorbei heute war der letzte tag norbert
wie für die deutschen seit dem de hat
drei weitere medaillen gewonnen und das
goldene dutzend voll gemacht insgesamt
eine gute sportliche bilanz später mehr
dazu wir schauen jetzt nämlich erstmal
auf die politische bilanz der
olympischen spiele unsere themen
die olympische flamme ist erloschen mit
einer großen feier endenden peking die
winterspiele
drohgebärden in der ukraine krise
russland und belarus verlängern ihr
manöver gleichzeitig gibt es aber auch
wieder diplomatische gespräche
nach dem sturm ist vor dem sturm antonia
nimmt kurs auf deutschland mit orkanböen
und viel regen
die olympischen winterspiele in peking
sind geschichte was bleibt neben dem
sportlichen dramen unter folgen es waren
nach den sommerspielen in tokio jetzt
schon die zweiten spiele unter strengen
corona beschränkungen spiele geprägt von
politischen kontroversen und
diplomatischen boykott der gastgeber
china nutze das sportgroßereignis um
sich politisch zu inszenieren stefanie
schöneborn mit der abschlussfeier und
einer bilanz
diese abschlussfeier wird filmisch
eingeläutet und doch bleibt ein ungutes
gefühl bei diesen pekinger spielen wir
sehen einen zufriedenen chinesischen
präsidenten der die spiele für sein land
als triumph verbucht
es ist immer so dass olympische spiele
für autoritäre system an der
leistungsschau sind das heißt sie zeigen
dort dass sie es können dass sie
überlegen sind wettbewerbsfähig sind in
china geht es um mehr als nur gewonnenen
medaillen
hier geht es auch um den stärker
werdenden nationalismus ziehen ping hat
mit den spielen und einem völlig
ergebenen olympischen komitee neue
nationale helden geschaffen selten waren
olympische spiele so politisch wie in
peking auch wenn ioc präsident bach
immer wieder die neutralität der spiele
beteuert für die meisten sportler war
der austragungsort china das größte
problem das umfeld war sehr schwierig
pandemie bedingt aber natürlich auch die
besondere situation in china insgesamt
es waren abgeschirmte spiele in einem
land das kein rechtsstaat ist kritische
aussagen zu menschenrechten und
meinungsfreiheit waren bei den spielen
unter strafandrohung verboten und das
olympische komitee
stattdessen heute eine verbeugung vor
china mit
diesen wirklich außergewöhnlichen
olympischen winterspielen in peking
begrüßen wir china als wintersportland
und somit enden die umstrittenen winter
spiele von peking die nächsten werden in
vier jahren in italien stattfinden
rolf roller für uns in peking wie sehr
waren die olympischen winterspiele jetzt
für china ein image-gewinn
ich glaube schon dass der präsident der
chinesische der ansicht ist dass ihm das
politisch sehr sehr nutzt dieses spieler
haben es wirklich gebracht vor den augen
der weltöffentlichkeit china als modern
als kreativ und vor allem als stabil zu
zeigen das wichtigste wohl die korona
politik der chinesischen regierung ist
aufgegangen es gab keinen großen
ausbruch darauf ist man sehr sehr stolz
die sportstätten sind eigentlich von
allen als technische meisterwerke gelobt
worden das soll für chinesische
innovation und wettbewerbsfähigkeit
stellen und dann ist das land doch
relativ stabil geblieben es hat
keinerlei politischen unruhen gegeben
weder in hongkong noch in china das hat
man es auch nicht erwartet aber trotzdem
ist das etwas was sie als ein
markenzeichen zeigt wie stabil das land
ist und damit kommen wir zu der
schattenseite der spiele nämlich das
alles ist eben unter dem großen problem
der menschenrechtsverletzung die hier in
china tätig die stattfinden hat das ist
das passiert und dafür steht eben peking
auch für eine zweiteilung der welt die
deutlich geworden ist die autokraten
dieser welt haben repräsentanten nach
peking geschickt die demokratischen
länder eben nicht und diese zweiteilung
ist sehr sehr deutlich geworden bei den
olympischen spielen und man sieht das ja
leider jetzt auch euro was die
auswirkungen sind danke für diese
politische bilanz und voller
in russland ukraine konflikt laufen
weiter die drähte heiß so hat heute
frankreichs präsident marco erneut
sowohl mit dem russischen staatschef
putin als auch mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky telefoniert alle
seiten sprachen sich für eine
diplomatische lösung für die umkämpfte
ostukraine aus sorgen bereitet dass das
russische militär sein manöver in
belarus verlängert christian sen
panzer rollen übers feld kampfjet
donnern das russische spieler russische
militärmanöver in belarus sollte heute
eigentlich enden aber es geht weiter
offizielle begründung erhöhte
militärische aktivität an den
außengrenzen des unionsstaates und die
angespannte lage im don was alles nur
übung wie es heißt
unser land hilft russland nicht die
ukraine zu erobern und russland tut es
auch nicht wir wollen die ukraine nicht
erobern
russland soldaten bleiben also in
belarus trotz anderslautender
versprechen des kremls und in der ost
ukraine beschießen und beschuldigen sich
die ukrainische armee und die
prorussischen separatisten gegenseitig
tausende verletzungen der waffenruhe
allein gestern
europa weiter in sorge vor einem krieg
die deutsche verteidigungsministerium
kündigt bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz an deutschland
werde mehr in die verteidigung und das
militär investieren wer beim
verlässlicher partner sein wir werden
unsere zusagen einhalten dafür auch die
voraussetzungen schaffen und wir werden
kontinuierlich diese
verteidigungsausgaben auch erhöhen am
nachmittag telefonierte frankreichs
präsident marc rommel wieder mit
wladimir putin beide präsidenten so
heißt es wollen jetzt für eine schnelle
waffenruhe an der frontlinie sorgen wir
haben die situation in der ost ukraine
zu eskalieren droht soll es jetzt wieder
die diplomatie richten eine waffenruhe
gab es schon öfter wirklich funktioniert
hat sie nie und trotz aller
krisengespräche hält russland das
drohpotenzial weiter hoch auch us
präsident biden hat wladimir putin neue
gespräche angeboten gleichzeitig warnen
die usa weiter vor einer invasion
russlands in die ukraine
zur corona lage die britische königin
elizabeth ii zweite ist mit dem virus
infiziert die 95-jährige habe leichte
symptome meldet der palast bei uns in
deutschland gehen die infektionszahlen
weiter zurück in der diskussion über
eine allgemeine impfpflicht hat
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel klar
stellung bezogen eine impfpflicht ab 18
sei dringend nötig sagte sie der bild am
sonntag denn im herbst könnten
gefährliche mutation drohen
dass der wind uns alle ein ganzes
wochenende lang durchschüttelt das kommt
selten vor und dieses sturm wochenende
ist noch nicht vorbei das merken viele
die bahn fahren wollen noch immer sind
viele strecken gesperrt züge fallen aus
was der sturm bisher angerichtet hat
beschäftigte feuerwehren und andere
helferinnen und helfer heute den ganzen
tag über über das was war und was kommt
volker check ohne oberleitung kein strom
ohne strom kein zug die diagnose ist
simpel und deswegen ist der
instandhaltung stop der bahn heute nacht
ausgerückt hier soll die strecke
zwischen düsseldorf und duisburg wieder
flott gemacht werden rund 2000
mitarbeiter sind im einsatz seit den
ersten stürmen am mittwoch waren
zwischenzeitlich mehr als 6000 kilometer
des netzes nicht befahrbar mehr als die
bahn befürchtet hatte aktuell können wir
etwa drei viertel des fernverkehrs in
deutschland fahren aber der norden und
nordosten ist weiterhin stark betroffen
und wird das auch am morgigen montag
seien die orkantiefs ziellinie und senat
haben in wenigen tagen erhebliche
schäden verursacht weil dieser fähre in
hamburg brach plötzlich das front
fenster in tausend stücke mindestens 1,4
milliarden euro müssen die versicherer
bundesweit auszahlen schätzen experten
und es geht heute nacht gleich weiter
sturmtief antonia zieht von nordwesten
bis südosten über die republik hinweg
mit windböen bis zu 115 kilometern pro
stunde sorgen macht vielen experten der
stark aufgeweichter boden die hier im
erzgebirge viele bäume werden einem
weiteren orkan nicht standhalten
kommen noch mal zur sportlichen seite
der olympischen winterspiele norbert zum
deutschen doppelerfolg ja und es war
sogar noch eine historische erfolg ein
historischer sieg von francesco
friedrich das erste mal überhaupt dass
ein fahrer bei zwei winterspielen
nacheinander alle wettbewerbe gewonnen
hat viermal gold in folge für den bob
dominator der könig des bobsports thront
über allen francesco friedrich torsten
marx candy bauer und alexander schiller
schieben den schlitten richtung sieg und
der 31 jährige friedrich bleibt souverän
an den lenkseilen nach dem triumph im
zweier vor fünf tagen in der olympischen
eisrinne von lenzing jetzt auch gold im
viererbob
nicht schaffen also respekt und vielen
dank an euch
silber für johannes lochner und seine
mannschaft sie bestätigen die dominanz
der deutschen schlitten bei diesen
spielen bronze geht an justin krebs und
team aus kanada
und quasi auf den letzten drücker gab es
dann noch einmal eine medaille eine ski
alpin medaille für deutschland silber im
team event und das war eine echte
überraschung
und es hätte für das deutsche team sogar
noch besser enden können denn im ersten
der vier duelle konnte lena dürr hier
links im bild gegen die
österreicherinnen katharina truppe ihr
team in führung bringen da aber julian
rauchfuss und emma eicher das ziel
entweder zu spät oder gar nicht
erreichten musste alexander schmid gegen
johannes strolz unbedingt mit
ausreichend vorsprung gewinnen
es fehlen 19 und
ja wir können alle mit entscheidenden
lächeln heimfliegen und freuen uns auch
wie das auf zu hause trotz der
niederlage ein versöhnlicher abschluss
in peking für den deutschen alpinen
skisport und
ein letzter blick auf den
medaillenspiegel norwegen triumphiert
mit 16 mal gold deutschland vor
gastgeber china zweiter mit zwölf
olympiasiegen eine gute bilanz aus
deutscher sicht in etwa vergleichbar mit
den olympia erfolgen vor vier jahren und
im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga schlägt bayern
münchen greuther fürth mit 4 2 1 1
online schön und wir schauen noch auf
die wetteraussichten es bleibt
wechselhaft mit etwas sonne kräftigen
schauern und einzelnen gewittern
oberhalb von etwa 500 metern gibt es
auch schnee stürmischer südwestwind mit
schweren sturmböen fünf bis zehn grad
marietta slomka hat um 21.45 das
heute-journal für sie und jetzt geht's
hier weiter mit berlin direkt mit schock
und manager